hey I quickly wanted to talk about the  essay competition of lab 42 they're not  sponsoring me in any way I just think  it's really cool what they're doing it's  completely free they're asking the  question which fundamental principles of  intelligence must be considered in the  successful design of artificial  intelligence the winning essay is  awarded 2000 Swiss Francs I believe the  second and third place also win some  money the final call is for in like two  days so the end of the year in GMT the  essay is supposed to be two thousand to  three thousand words that's like four  pages or five pages or so and it's  really really open so you can submit  anything from biology to computational  to mathematical neuroscientific  philosophical psychological social or  any other perspective so if you are in a  writing mood and have a bit of time the  next two days uh consider submitting  here and consider checking out lab 42  again not a sponsor but really cool  organization that was it